okay let's check out a great Orwellian
moment on cable television
Seema Verma is a pro Trump healthcare
consultant she's on Donald Trump's White
House coronavirus Task Force she's very
articulate she's very good at masking
and hiding the failings of the Trump
administration by dressing them up with
flowery language and consultants speaks
so very often when Seema Verma is
talking it sounds number-one like she's
actually saying things and number two it
sounds like she's actually making sense
when she's not here's an example it's a
few days old I haven't had time to get
to it until today Seema Verma was on Fox
News she was interviewed by Edie Henry
and Edie Henry asked about Mike Pence
saying the best model of coronavirus for
the United States is what happened in
Italy now you might be confused you
might wonder shouldn't our model be
South Korea which had the first case
within hours of when the US had its
first case South Korea immediately
developed a test they established fever
clinics they isolated and quarantined
people they did contact tracing and
still to this day South Korea doesn't
have 200 deaths that's not an error not
I'm not talking about 2,000 South Korea
still does not have 200 coronavirus
deaths but for some reason Mike Pence
says our model is Italy so Seema is
asked about this and she says something
completely wacky she essentially says we
suck at dealing with coronavirus because
we are a free country and countries that
are managing it well are not free
countries listen to her say it don't
take my word for it what is the vice
president referring to when he says the
best model we have for America is what's
happened in Italy well I think that if
you look at these other countries if you
look at China and South Korea right
though they had very different
approaches we're a free country we're
giving recommendations to the American
people and hoping that they're going to
adhere to those in terms of what
happened in Italy the strain on the
health care system those are the things
that lessons that we are trying to learn
from we're trying to prepare our health
care system some of the the recent
regulations that we pulled back from
just earlier this week are going to have
a really big impact on our health care
system it's giving them that flexibility
at the low
level China and South Korea are
different she says because we are a free
country China is an authoritarian
country for sure but South Korea South
Korea ranks higher than the United
States in the democracy index in 2019
South Korea ranked 23rd in the world in
the democracy index the u.s. ranking
behind South Korea 25th in the democracy
index how are we a free country and
South Korea is not and in fact on that
same ranking Italy ranks 35th in the
democracy index lower than both South
Korea and the United States this is what
happens when healthcare consultants
manage your response to a pandemic you
get garbage like this perpetuated in the
media and the real difference is that in
South Korea you don't have incompetent
slow failed leadership you don't have
people whose ignorance is weaponized
such that they are packing churches and
beaches bragging weeks into what should
be self isolation and SEMA is not the
only person attacking the freedom of
South Korea here's the Surgeon General
girona Adam Jerome Adams also saying
listen we're not authoritarian like
South Korea why the shift from local
autonomy to the federal government
giving very strict recommendations and
perhaps it a more draconian ones coming
up well that's a great question we are
not an authoritarian nation so we have
to be careful when we say let's do what
China did let's do what what South Korea
did a lot of our public health authority
live in the state and local level and
I've worked for a local health
department we are not authoritarian like
South Korea they rank higher than the
United States on the democracy index
this is really ugly stuff and what it
comes down to is they're just desperate
to find any way to deflect blame whether
it's saying no one could have predicted
this whether it's saying we're not an
authoritarian country like South Korea
they don't care that it's just a game of
deflect deflect lie and distort and this
is what happens when you put people like
Seema Verma in positions of power when
you
dealing with a public health emergency
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink Asst to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video